okay welcome back everyone let's get
started
so welcome to lecture 10.
the topic for today will be neural
networks
and back propagation under the umbrella
of deep learning
uh so before we jump into today's topics
uh
quick recap of what we covered um in
lecture nine
last friday so lecture nine was all
about bayesian methods
and we saw two different kinds of
bayesian methods
parametric and non-parametric with an
example each
in parametric we saw bayesian linear
regression
and the general approach in um
with with beige with bayesian methods
for supervised machine learning
in a parameterized setting is to have a
parameter theta
and we assume it is distributed
according to a prior distribution
some p of theta right and this is the
assumption that distinguishes
bayesian methods from frequence methods
that we assign
a prior probability to the unknown
parameters
and then um again in the supervised
setting we assume
y comes from some distribution p
of y given ah theta comma x which is
also called the likelihood
and from this from the observed data
where x and y are your training set we
construct the posterior distribution
where theta hat which is now a random
variable
is is uh is derived as p of theta given
x comma y using the base rule
and that's you know that's how the name
bayesian methods comes into picture
because the way we construct
the posterior is using the bayes rule
there is no gradient descent there is no
maximum likelihood
we just condition on the observed data
and we get our posterior distribution
and then using the posterior
distribution we can then construct the
posterior predictive distribution
which um which is used for making
predictions on
new unseen data examples right so y
star condition on x star comma x comma y
what this means is x comma y
is your training set that you observed
in the past and x star
is the new input that you encounter and
we need to
make a prediction about y star and what
we do is construct
a distribution over y star given the new
input and all the past
training inputs and that is called the
posterior predictive distribution
and this is what the posterior
predictive distribution is defined to be
and we saw that there was also a pr
suppose where the steps for this was
described in detail
we saw that this distribution can be
expressed as
an expectation of p of y star given
x star and theta hat where theta hat is
comes from the posterior distribution
the interpretation of this
is that for every possible
setting of the theta vector we get a
different model
a predictive model and the posterior
predictive distribution
takes the average across all possible
models that can possibly exist you know
that is infinitely many
but the average is a weighted average
where the weights are decided according
to the posterior distribution
right and
so so this this ah kind of
averaging across models ah where we do
not
commit ourselves to only any one given
single model
but we are still kind of hedging our
bets against all possible models but
we just weight them differently
according to the posterior distribution
and this is um um as you know
there's uh you might read this in
several other places
as well this makes bayesian methods kind
of
prone to overfitting right this this
makes it fundamentally prone to over
fitting
there is no there is no other extra
steps you need to take
in order to make your models not over
fit and we'll go into the
into more details about this probably in
wednesday or friday's lecture
ah but this this kind of model averaging
where we do not commit ourselves to one
single model
which may which could uh which could be
due to noise in your data
right we don't commit ourselves to one
single model but instead we consider
all the possible models the infinitely
many possible models that you get
for different values of theta and we
take a weighted average across the
predictions where the weights are
decided by the posterior distribution
right so this is in the parametric
setting where a theta exists
right so this this this whole setting
this whole exercise is
in revolves around theta and and that's
why we call it uh
parametric uh bayesian methods in the
nonparametric approach
we assume y equals some function f
f of x plus ah some noise where
noise i epsilon comes from a normal
distribution and we assume that
there is a prior distribution on f just
the way there was a prior distribution
on theta
here we assume there is a prior
distribution on on f
and that prior distribution is a
gaussian process so this is called
a gaussian process prior and in order to
define a gaussian process prior
its parameter so to speak is a mean and
a covariance function so this is
actually a mean function
which i have just written as 0 it means
it evaluates to 0 everywhere
and the way to think of a gaussian
process is with the same analogy as
we went from vector to functions as an
infinite dimension
infinite extension of a vector similarly
a gaussian process is an infinite
extension of
a multivariate uh gaussian distribution
right and for vectors to functions the
relation was
indices of vectors become the domain of
the function
similarly indices of your multivariate
gaussian become
the domain of the functions over which
we are we are
defining the gp okay and we saw a few
properties about mult
ah about multivariate gaussians so we
saw the normalization property that if
we integrate out all the data
it the density of the multivariate
gaussian must evaluate to one
we saw the marginalization property
where um
suppose in this example if you want to
marginalize out b from this
multivariate distribution then all we
get is
a and mu a and sigma a square so all the
rows and columns
that correspond to the the
variable that we are marginalizing out
just wipe them out of your multivariate
gaussian
it's that simple that's that's a special
property about gaussians which
uh don't don't exist for other
distributions in general
and that's that makes uh gaussian
gaussian distributions are really nice
and then we saw the conditioning rule
where the multivariate version
appears complex at first but if we see
the analogy
in case of two dimensional gaussians ah
the conditioning looks like this a given
b is again a normal distribution if a
and b
are jointly disputed then a given b is
again a normal distribution
whose mean is given by this the
interpretation here is
with when when the value of b is given
first
we standardize it that is divided by its
mean
and divided by its standard deviation so
it's like a z value
transform the z value by the correlation
coefficient and then
do the reverse transform like the the
inverse z
transform back into mu a uh by by
scaling it by
a is standard deviation and adding a is
mean right that's how we
we we update the a
is a mean and then the covariance
of a or the variance of a given b is the
variance of e scaled by
1 minus rho square where rho is the
correlation coefficient so what this
means is if
if rho is 1 if a and b are perfectly
correlated
then by observing b the variance of a
reduces to 0
right 1 minus 1 is 0 which means you
know exactly what a is
and similarly if the covariance between
a and b
is 0 if there's no covariance whatsoever
then the variance of a given b
will still be mu of a square so there
was no reduction in uncertainty by
observing b
if there was no correlation between them
right
so these these properties using these
properties we constructed
gaussian process regression so the
analogous to this we define f and f star
where
these are the function f evaluated at
our training set
and function f evaluated at our test
sets
and this follows a multivariate gaussian
distribution
because that is the property of gaussian
processes where you take any finite sub
sample of your gaussian process
that will be a gaussian distribution
multivariate gaussian distribution and
this is the
kernel function evaluated at every
possible
pairs right and so this is the this is
we get this by marginalizing out the gp
from the gp all the variable all the
test exam test and train examples that
we have not observed so marginalize out
everything that we have not seen
and this condenses your gaussian process
into a multivariate gaussian
evaluated only at the test and
train points and the assumption was
y equals f plus epsilon right and
ah using the addition property of
gaussians which i forgot to recap using
the addition property of gaussians
y equals f plus epsilon so f plus
epsilon gives us this epsilon ah it you
still have the same mu
but because uh f and epsilon are
independent the covariances add up
and epsilon is is a diagonal matrix so
you only add along the diagonals
and you get a distribution for
y is given access and using this
using the conditioning property we
construct the posterior predictive
distribution
which which evaluates to some form it
might look
complex but this whole expression for
the so the variance
is exactly this but a multivariate
version of this
right it just looks more complex but
it's essentially the same
and um similarly the mean is is is uh
very similar to that
and and this is all gaussian process is
about
it's very simple you perform one
conditioning and
and that's it right so any questions
about gps before we move on to
uh deep learning today yes
they will not be prone to overfitting
yeah
so in general bayesian methods are are
you know you consider them as not prone
to overfitting
uh because um the the the intuition
there is that overfitting happens due to
the fact that you're committing yourself
to just one model
given your training data which which may
be swayed by
swayed due to noise right and and here
we're kind of hedging our bets by not
committing to
any single model we are considering all
the possible models that could possibly
exist
and we are taking the average across
them where the average is weighted by
the
weight by the posterior distribution
well look um we'll go into details to
that on
on wednesday and friday and and um i
would postpone that
you know answer to that uh for a couple
more days but in general the intuition
is that
with bayesian methods the at least at
the theoretical level the concept of
overfitting does not exist
all right so today the topic for today
is neural networks and
and and deep learning
right and again in order to ah motivate
deep learning and neural networks right
the the
so the models that we have seen so far
for example um
we saw we saw linear regression we saw
logistic regression glms etcetera
they've all been linear
and one way we kind of introduced
non-linearity
was using kernels right and also using
feature maps
and we saw that kernels and feature maps
are kind of very tightly
related to each other right for every
feature map is
a feature map is associated with some
kernel
right and that was one way to introduce
non-linearity and neural networks is
another way
right in neural networks the
the high level picture to have in your
mind is that when we defined
a feature map for example in in problem
set one
the last question we we explore
different kinds of feature maps on a
simple
regression task that gave us you know
very flexible
hypotheses and the feature map we used
there was you know for example we used a
polynomial feature map v of
x equals 1
x x square x cube and maybe things like
sine x you know you can add you can add
more features
right and the responsibility of coming
up with such a feature map
was in the hands of the designer the one
who was training the model the one
you know the data scientist who is
trying to fit this model on on
ah on the data had to you know use their
intuition
use their creativity to come up with a
suitable feature map
right and that is is uh hard work right
you need to have some kind of an
intuition you need to
you know think hard to see to
to make some decisions about what
features to include what features not to
include
and at a high level what neural networks
does for you is is give you a way in
which
features themselves are learned
automatically
right so the models that we've seen so
far
given features we constructed linear
models
for you know regression classification
etcetera
with neural net networks not only are we
learning that
model given the features but we are also
learning
what the right set of features are right
and the the
its probably best best explained by
looking at an example
of of what i mean by that
so supposing we have some input x
you know in r d
and lets say
we represent x as a set of nodes
where we have d
number of nodes so this corresponds to x
one
this corresponds to x d right
and the way we constructed logistic
regression for example
you know just to consider an example was
we had a parameter vector
and that parameter vector
so here ah just like svms we're going to
switch our notation
and use w and b
for weights and biases we had
w 1 w 2
w 3 l w
d and we had
bias and over here
this was summation
i equals one to d x
i w i
plus b right so this is
ah you can think of this as theta
transpose x
where theta was the collection of w and
b
and x is the x vector along with the
intercept term 1
right and let us call this
z that is z equals
x transpose w plus b
and on the other side
let us call this a equals g
of z where g is some kind of
ah a non-linearity right for example
in in the case of logistic regression g
was
1 over 1 plus e to the minus z
or g of z
was 1 over 1 plus e to the minus 3
right so this was ah this was logistic
regression just visualized in a
different way as nodes
and connections right and this is the
view
or this is the interpretation that we
are going to use
for extending this further and construct
neural networks out of them
right so we used to have a parameter
vector theta
instead of that we visualize
parameters as connections between some
node to another node
right and in neural neural network
terminology
these nodes are called neurons right
so um to clarify
the reason why they are called neurons
is because early in the development of
neural networks the design of of of this
this kind of a design was inspired by
how neurons
possibly work based on the theory of how
neurons work back then
but um it's it's you know you see a lot
of
literature where people say neural
networks
mimic neurons and that's just not the
case right neural networks
when they were designed were inspired by
how people thought neurons worked back
then
right and uh in no way whatsoever do
neural networks
mimic neurons or mimic the brain right
so you know
just have that in the back of your mind
and neurons is probably
um therefore a poor choice of word you
can call it nodes and that's just fine
but you know we call it neurons assuming
you guys
know that you know this is not how
actual neurons work
right so there is some non-linearity ah
which takes for takes us from z
to an output a we are going to call a as
the output of the non-linearity
right and together this this entire
assembly
will call it a neuron
and
in this particular configuration
x1 to xd is fixed
right there there is no feature map here
x1 through xd is fixed
and everything that that we have seen
over here is basically
exactly logistic regression with no
difference whatsoever right
and we could for example if this was
logistic regression
then we would call this our y hat as
a right and we would have the right
label
y and we will construct a loss
y comma y hat is equal to
y log y hat plus
1 minus y log
1 minus y hat and in place of y hat
we would express y hat as a function of
w's and b's
and perform gradient ascent right that
that was logistic regression
any questions on this of of why this is
similar to logistic regression
is a question no question
right yeah so ah this this is a logistic
regression
viewed in terms of connections and and
neurons
so to speak now the
what we are going to do next is
basically
take this network now come back to this
network view
and start growing this network so
x one through
x d this is our input layer again
right and
in place of one
neuron let us have a collection of
neurons
over here we had a set of
weights connecting
we had a set of weights that connected
the input to as
uh from excess the the input data
to the input of this neuron and just
like that
let us add a second neuron here and give
it
its own set of weights
right and this is as if we are
we are trying to train two different
logistic regression models in parallel
you know that is the image
you know that is the picture to have we
have one sets of one set of
ah that connect x's
to this neuron and another set of w's
that connect the x's to the second
neuron
they have their own
bias term
as well right
and similar similarly
there is going to be a z here goes
through the
non-linearity to get an a similarly the
the the z's are basically the linear
combinations of
x's with w's plus b the same thing over
here
and let's call this b one and b
two b2 and this is
z1 z2 and a1
and a2 so from z to a we apply the g
function the non
linearity to take the linear combination
we get a scalar run it through the
non-linearity we get another scalar
right and
we we can continue this so similarly we
can have
a z 3 and an a3
again that has its own sets of weights
and its own bias b3
so you get z3 as the sum over
[Music]
x w1 w two x two w d x d plus b three
and then apply the non-linearity and you
get a three
right and not only can we
add multiple models like this we can
then start nesting them
in the sense these three the outputs of
these three that is
a1 a2 a3 can now become the input for
another logistic regression
is going to be a z and an a
similarly
a second logistic regression using the
inputs
as the outputs from the first layer
z and a
and so on we can nest this even further
next question
so the question was uh won't they all
learn the same same same model aren't
they going to be just copies of the same
model
um in potentially it can and we will
address that shortly
is that another question my question is
yeah we'll come to that we'll come to
that for now we're just constructing a
network
uh using base components that we've seen
before basically logistic regression
right
so take logistic regression create
multiple copies of it
take the outputs of those logistic
regressions feed them as input
to you know unnecessary logistic
regression and so on
and this kind of a network can be
arbitrarily deep
and arbitrarily wide right and it can be
arbitrarily wide
to different levels at different layers
and we're going to call start giving
them names
so this collection of neurons
we're going to call it the input layer
right and
and this over here is the output layer
and these are called hidden layers so
this would be
hidden layer 1 hidden layer 2.
right and this overall network you can
call it
maybe a three layer network right so you
have
an output layer hidden layer hidden
layer one hidden layer two so you have
um three layers and generally we don't
count the input layer you know input is
just
input right and
soon we are going to give more more
precise terminologies to each each of
these uh
weights and and weights and biases and
activations
but before that it's important to get
this general intuition of
of how neural networks are kind of
constructed
this is an example of a very simple
neural network
there are lots of different choices for
the g function you don't always have to
use the logistic
logistic function but the general idea
is more or less the same
that is we take a linear model
with some activation um
in glms we saw that for different kinds
of
outputs we use different kinds of g's
similarly
here we can use there is a wide variety
of choices
of the activation function that we can
use so g is also called the activation
function
right and using this this linear model
building block we start
assembling a big network as though these
are you know think of them as lego
blocks right
you place one block here one block here
one block here and then started building
yet another layer on top and so on
right and
and and now once we construct a layer
a network with you know some number of
layers each layer being
you know some having some particular
width and finally
at the output layer the output
the a of the last layer will be
considered our y hat
right and then we are going to get the
true label y
and we are going to apply construct some
kind of a loss
right previously we would take the
output of the very first layer
y hat and apply our loss but now we are
going to nest these
building blocks into a more complex
network
and we are going to construct the
network that eventually we are going to
have a single output
and that output will be the
the prediction made by this network on
which we're going to apply a loss
and this is the big picture to have in
mind deep learning is basically
adding depth by cascading simple
building blocks
using non-linearities in the middle
any question about the big picture we
before we start defining
terminology and giving specific
numbers here this question
the choice of activation function
yes so the question is uh do the uh the
activation function the choice that we
used
in the first layer should it be the same
uh say for the second layer
right and in in theory they can be
different
you can use different activation
functions for different neurons even
then it need not even be the same within
the same layer but in practice
we generally tend to use the same
activation function throughout the
network but you know that's that's
that's a convention that is not a
requirement
good question right so now um
let's start this question
yeah we're going to come to that so so
the question was if we have a loss
function here what are we going to
update
the answer is once we apply a loss
function we need to calculate gradients
with respect to
every single connection and bias right
the the um the goal of
of of our training is to first
come up with a network architecture and
once you come up with a network
architecture
you take your data start feeding your
input you get some
predicted output calculate the loss
and then calculate the the gradient of
that loss with respect to every
connection
right in parallel and take a gradient
descent
step to to minimize that loss in along
the direction of that gradient
yeah yeah yeah we will we'll come to
that of you know generally
stochastic gradient descent is the one
that is most commonly used
ah and in fact a variant of that called
minibase stochastic gradient
will come to that right so lets lets ah
start giving some precise terminology
so that we are clear of what we are we
are
referring to so
we will use um
all the all the connections we will use
the letter w
so w will mean connection
right and b will be bias
and z will be
w dot something
plus b so z will always be linear in w
and linear in b and linear with whatever
we multiply b
w by a will always be
g of some z
and as
as to distinguish the different
z's and the different a's and the
different b's and w's
we are going to use the notation where a
superscript
identifies the layer
a superscript is going to identify the
layer and a subscript
is going to identify which node
in that layer we are referring to right
so
we are going to have a i
j i i
i so the a is there are only so a's and
z's and b's
is a vector per layer whereas the
weights the connections are
a matrix so these are vectors so this is
the vector a
this is the vector z and this is the
vector b
and you have one such vector per layer
one vector of a one vector of z and one
vector of b per layer
but we have one matrix w per layer
so w is going to be it's also called the
weight matrix
and that's why it has two indices i and
j
and the
the very first input
x will also be called
a zero so it is like
the output of the zeroth layer so you
kind of bootstrapping
this this hierarchy by considering the
inputs to be the output of the zeroth
layer you know
but we're just going to consider the x's
as just given so think of x's as the
output of the activation from the zeroth
layer
and
so z one
[Music]
z one we are referring to this vector
z superscript square bracket 1 refers to
this z
vector and in that let's consider z 1 1
so z 1 1 is
in the in the in the z vector of the
first layer the first
element of that vector
will be
sum over
w
j sum over j w one
j x
j plus b one
right so w is now a matrix that has
so matrix has has two axes
two dimensions the
number of rows in the matrix is the
number of
neurons in that layer and the number of
columns in that matrix
is the number of neurons in the input
layer in the previous layer
right so w is a matrix
w l is the weight matrix
where
the number of rows is the num
is the is the number of neurons in the
layer
right so this is number
of
neurons in the health layer
and the number of columns is the number
of neurons
in the l minus one layer
right so thats ah thats a w matrix
and z one one is therefore
the first row
of the weight matrix
dot product it with the a0 vector that
is dot product it with the input
right and that that is basically
doing this for you w1 x1 w2 x2 w3 xv and
so on
plus b1
and similarly
z 2 of 1
is equal to
w 2 of
1 this time i'm going to write it as a
transpose
so that just to simplify
0 plus b2
this is just the the dot product and and
in in this version i've written as a dot
product
and so on and so that gives that gives
us
the collection of z's
and similarly then a of
1 1 equals g of
z 1 1.
the activation functions are applied
element wise
right for
a given value of z that was calculated
with the
dot product and adding of the sum the a
function is applied element wise
separate
the g function is applied element wise
separately to each of the z
values to get the corresponding a values
right and so on and and similarly once
we have
constructed the a1 vector so a
superscript one is the output of the
first layer
so in this case the vector that comes
out
of the first layer will be a superscript
one
right and the dimension of this vector
is
equal to the number of neurons in the
first layer
is that clear and we can we can continue
this
this ah style of nesting even further so
we will we will then have
z 2
next question
z2 is written in matrix form
so w so w is a matrix
[Music]
my question is essentially agnostic of
which layer
good question let's let's uh
is is this a the one you're referring to
yeah yeah
so a a11
means the output of the first layer and
the first element of that vector
is equal to the activation function
applied on
the first element of the z of
the z vector of the first layer
so the z vector not just one of the dots
yeah so so z
so let me let me um write this in
vector notice so here we were
calculating it element wise
so this is z 1 1 this is z superscript 1
subscript 2 this is
z superscript 1 subscript 3 right
and if you want to write it in vector
form then you would write this as
z of superscript 1 is equal to
w of superscript one
times a of supers
of superscript zero plus b
superscript one
right now we are writing this in vector
notation where z superscript one
is this entire z vector
right and that is equal to the w matrix
times the input vector
plus element wise addition due to the
summing up of the b the bias
so z is just a linear combination of w's
and a's
plus the b's
i would say don't think of a as the
probability if you take it through a
sigmoid you get a value between 0 and 1
for now don't treat it as a probability
just think of it as you know some
output of some non-linearity right so
the a is if if
if g is the sigmoid then a will be
between zero and one yes
good question any any other any other
questions
right so this is a compact way of
writing these element wise operations
right so the full the full z vector that
is uh the vector zs
before applying the nonlinearity
this vector of size 3 is equal to a
matrix w
in this case the matrix w will be 3
cross d
where d is the dimension of the input
so the input dimension goes to the
number of columns
and 3 is the number of outputs that's
the number of
number of neurons in this layer so that
would be 3 here
d here so w 1 will be 3 cross d
a 0 that is the a0
is the x vector
right a 0 is d dimensional
so this would be according to this
network
this is 3 cross d
and this is d dimension
and this is 3 dimension
and z will also be there for
three dimension this is clear
and and and then we apply the the
non-linearity
on this z that is on the left half of
these circles
you apply the non-linearity to jump over
to the right half of the
circle to get a and the g function is
applied
separately element wise
so in this case three is the number of
neurons
the number of input nodes is d
dimensional
so the number of neurons here we have
chosen this to be 3
right and the w matrix takes you from d
to 3.
right so the w matrix takes you from d
to three
when you up multiply it with x
which is three ah which which is d
dimensional
you multiply the w matrix with x
and because the number of rows in w is
three you get a vector of
dimension three and to that you add
a b vector which is also of dimension
three
so you get a z vector of dimension three
any other questions so
the thing to kind of keep in mind is
whenever we we see some kind of a
subscript
at least in case of logistic regression
when when we thought when we saw an x j
we thought of this as a scalar
where x was in
rd right however when we see a
superscript right we are still referring
to
you know the vector or scalar or
whatever it is but
it's only identifying which layer we are
at right
so z of 1 is not the first element of z
just means it's the z vector of the
first layer
right so the superscript square bracket
refers to the layer number
right
if something is not clear please stop me
it's it's uh super important that
you know you understand this really well
because you know once we go to back
propagation
uh we're just going to use all these all
these notations very liberally there so
you know
if there's any question feel free to
stop me as many number of times you want
so so now a1
loosely speaking we can call it g of
z1 where you can think of g as
uh the non-linearity for example the
sigmoid being applied element wise
separately to each
element in the input vector right and
then similarly
z 2 is now
w 2 times
a one plus b
two right
and this gives us a three ah
sorry a two equals
g of z
two
and so on right and then z
three equals
w 3 of a 2
plus b
3 and a 3
equals g of
z three and you can
and you can take this as arbitrarily
deep as you want
right and this
this depth is what
is what is the basically the reason why
we call this deep learning you know
uh the deeper your network is you know
the more deeper your deep learning is
you know so to speak right
so the the number of level the number of
degrees of nesting you have is called
the depth of your network
right and and this is what distinguishes
from now
simple linear models where then there
was pretty much no depth at all
right there was just one single layer
and the output of the layer was
the output of of your hypotheses right
and
we can go on and ah
and now the question is
why do we have this g to be
a non-linear function right what if
g was identity that is
what if g of
z was just z that is if a equals
z what would happen in that case yes
question
there is no point because it's only one
step
exactly so the reason why
you know the reason why it's important
to have
non-linearities is because if
z was just if g was just the identity
function
then a3
would have been just to simplify the
argument
we're going to ignore the b terms but
you can include the b terms here and and
the same argument will still hold
let's let's assume that the b's are just
0s for now so
a3 will be g of z3
right and g of z3 is just z3
right but z three is w three a two
so this is
w three
a two right but a 2
is g of z 3 and g is identity so this
is w 3 of
z 2 right but z 2 is w 2 of a 1. w3
w2 of a1
and similarly a1 is g of z1 if z is
identity then
you know this becomes z1
z one and this again
w three times w 2
times w 1 times
x right and
this is basically a matrix times a
matrix matrix and we can call this
sum w tilde times x
so if g were not a non-linear function
but assume it to be just some you know a
linear function
then this entire network
can now be represented as a single
matrix right which means we haven't
really
gone beyond the scope of linear models
so any such networks can be represented
by a linear model
if g is not a non-linear function
right and so g being non-linear
is essential to have depth be meaningful
otherwise all that no matter how many
levels deep your network is it can
always be collapsed into a single matrix
and it will effectively be as expressive
as a single layer network
this question layers can be
different
yeah so the question is what is what if
what if uh um
even though we have you know so many
matrices why is it you know still
effectively the same as one
one one way to think about that is you
can think of these
the the w matrices in your networks
which have arbitrary you know widths
as being uh a decomposition of your w
tilde matrix
right so you you take a w tilde matrix
and decompose it into product of
you know other matrices and those will
be your weight matrices
next question
so we're going to come to that so uh um
you mean why
g is the sigmoid yeah so
um
yeah so so z
so g of z clearly should not be just
z because then you know there is no
depth in the network
then the question is what can z be what
can g be rather
so g of z can be any function which is
uh non-linear but in deep learning
we choose you know some kind of a
nonlinear function that is also
monotonic
right so g of z equals 1 over
1 plus e to the minus z so that is the
familiar sigmoid function
now that works
g can sometimes be tan h
so tan h is basically e to the z plus
what is it minus
yeah e to the g to the e to the z minus
e to the minus z over
e to the z plus e to the z this is the
hyperbolic tangent
right and this also looks
very similar to ah the sigmoid except
instead from you know
zero to one it is minus one to plus one
you know
just a different choice and a very
common one
of g is relu
it is also called the rectified linear
unit and this is basically
max of z comma zero
what does this look like it basically
looks like this
ok so
this is z this is
value of z right
and similarly here you know ah this was
z
and this is tan h of z and here this was
z and this is sigmoid of c
this is z and this is the value of c
right ah
what rel u does is um if z
is negative it just sets it to 0 if it's
positive it leaves it as it is
and this is a non-linearity right and if
if gs are the value function then you
cannot represent
w as you know product of uh other w's
and and these are you know probably the
you know three most common choices of
of the activation function that are used
in practice
right so this is pretty much how we
construct a neural network
of this kind of an architecture so this
kind of an architecture is also called a
fully connected network
the reason why it's called fully
connected
is because in each layer
to the next layer we have a full
bipartite connection
every node in one layer is connected to
every other node in the
next layer or in the previous layer
right and
and and that's the reason this this kind
of a network architecture is called a
fully connected
neural network and the number of
layers you want to have and the number
of neurons in each layer that you want
to have
they are all configuration choices and
they are also called hyper parameters
this questions
is
yeah so the uh question is um
i guess you know um do the number of
layers
do the and the number of neurons that we
have you know does that
relate to over fitting and under fitting
right
yeah so how will we choose the right
number of layers and how do we choose
the right number of neurons per layer or
in general how do we choose
what activation function to choose what
activation function
function to use and the answer is almost
always cross validation
and the answer will be cross validation
for a lot of future questions as well
and that's just the nature of machine
learning right
um have a lot of
freedom lots of degrees of freedom to
tune a lot of different hyper parameters
and the right answer of what a hyper
parameter value needs to be is generally
not
obvious by you know just reading the
problem description or just by looking
at the data
if it were obvious there would be a lot
of theory and
there isn't a lot of theory for deciding
what is the right number of layers by
just looking at the data
or the what's the right activation to
use looking at the data
you can use some intuitions which you
might you know
develop over practice for a long time
but
more often than not even like the
world's best experts
they just generally tune it through
cross validation
have a hold out cross validation set and
fit your network on your training data
and see how well it performs on
you know validation data parameters like
alpha you have
either you can go down or up in this
case you can either like go this way or
this way how would you
how do those two movements relate
so what do you mean by alpha uh so like
learning oh the learning right yeah
but here we have two choices so let's
say you have you observe some
observation now you have the choice of
either going to be
or adding more layers how would you make
a choice
yeah and in fact you you still need to
choose alpha as well
you know like the choice of alpha hasn't
gone away so we need to choose alpha
we need to choose the number of layers
we need to choose
the number of neurons per layer we need
to choose what activation functions to
use right there are lots of
hyper parameters that you need to tune
in neural network right and
there are many strategies for doing
cross validation for example if it was
just learning great then you can you
could have done some kind of a binary
search you know sweep some region and
find a good learning rate but here
you basically have this
hyper cube of different hyper parameters
right and
each each point in this hypercube
represents some kind of a configuration
and the way you go about searching it is
um
people sometimes do something uh that's
called um a random search
we will we we're actually going to cover
uh strategies for
tuning your hyper parameters uh later
this week but in general
um the answer of how you how you choose
these values
is through cross validation right now
try some
you know come up with some possible
configurations see how well it works
or try some other configuration see how
well it works and you know
keep trying that until you feel
satisfied you know which is
not a very satisfactory answer but
that's exactly how it's done in practice
this question we still have the choice
are we going to come why we need a
learning rate we still haven't
seen how we you know optimized this yet
we are still talking about the network
architecture
yeah in general if if the width of the
network becomes extremely wide
or if the depth of the network becomes
extremely deep you're
you're absolutely you know it's
absolutely possible that you you may
over fit your network
uh overfit on your data and um
and which is why you need to do cross
validation where you know
you measure the performance on a
validation set and see that your
training
performance is very good test
validations such as not so good so
you're overfit
yes questions
are also parameters that
yeah so the question is is the depth and
the width uh
something that the model learns on its
own the answer is no
which is why it's called a hyper
parameter right so the parameters
in terms of terminology parameters are
those variables
which the model learns on its own using
gradient descent or whatever
hyper parameters are the ones uh are the
variables that
you as as you know a human being who's
building the
model will choose yeah so you know
the number of layers is is something you
decide before you start running your
gradient descent and that's called a
hyper parameter
exactly for cross validation you you try
different hyper parameters and see how
well
each configuration of hyper parameter
works on the validation set
so there is a lot of research where uh
research of on on how to um
most efficiently or even learn what the
right hyper parameters are going to be
and that's way beyond our scope right
now
but yes there is there is actual
research going on um to
to you know automatically learn the
hyper parameters yes
yes question
function
yeah so the question is should the
activation
functions be bounded because tan h and
sigmoid are bounded but relu is not
there are there are good reasons to keep
it bounded
and there are good reasons to not keep
it bounded as well
maybe we'll cover it later later today
or if not in the future
the the um the problem with
right so so maybe we are we are kind of
skipping ahead but in general
um the the problem
with a sigmoid network a sigmoid
function
like this is as you as you kind of ah
reach as as your z value goes farther
and farther away from zero
the the gradient of the sigmoid
is pretty much zero right
so which means
which means if if um as we will see uh
uh
later today if your gradient becomes
zero then your learning effectively
stops because you know when you when
you're doing gradient update if your
gradient is zero
your learning effectively stops
yeah so i i i i'm going to postpone that
for
you know another 20 minutes or so and
when we talk back propagation probably
that's going to be a better time to
discuss that
right so um moving on so
this is how we we construct a fully
connected network
and now once we have constructed it
you're going to see how we are going to
train this network
okay and that brings us to back
propagation
so to recall um
a naught is x right and
z 1 is w
1 times a naught
plus p 1
a 1 is g of
z 1 and z2
is w2 of
a1 plus 2
and a2 equals
g of z2
and we see this pattern of alternating
between z and a z and a
all the way until let us call it
a of say capital l where l is the number
of layers in your network
is equal to g of z of
l and then y hat
is equal to a l
right and then our loss
when use script l of y
y hat is equal to
for now we are going to assume we are
doing a classification problem rather
than regression
if it's regression you're going to have
you're going to see the squared error
here y minus y hat square
for regression this is going to be y
log y hat plus
1 minus y log
1 minus y hat
next question
what should be l minus 1
so if there are l layers should this be
l minus 1.
and we don't count that we don't count
the input layer
right so this is our loss and
the in order to
to train our network the
our goal is to do something like this
for l in one two
capital l
n equals
equals
l minus
so ah because we are treating this as a
loss
this should be the negative of the
likelihood of the log likelihood because
we are thinking of this as a loss
and because it is a loss we are doing
gradient descent
minus alpha times
partial derivative of l
partial
and similarly
p of l minus alpha
times partial
right so very similar to to gradient
ascend that we saw for logistic
regression in logistic regression we had
just
one set of theta vectors and we would
perform gradient ascent on that theta
vector
here we have a collection of w and b
ah matrices and vectors and we have l
number of these matrices and vectors and
what we want to do
is for each weight matrix and and
bias vector take the gradient of
the final loss right final loss all the
way at the end
with respect to the corresponding
weight layer of weight matrix of that
layer
and perform a gradient update like this
and similarly to the
bias term as well so this is our goal
and the way we go about
calculating these gradients is using an
algorithm called back propagation
right so back propagation helps us
calculate these gradients
but once we calculate the gradients we
perform
gradient descent on the last function
this question
so the question is is the stochastic in
this
case it is stochastic because ah
we are we have considered just one
example
right so yeah good question so think of
this as y i
so y hat i and
y i
yeah so this is just the ith example
right so for for a given example
this would be like the stochastic
gradient descent update rule
right now the question is now how are we
going to calculate these
um these derivatives
of l with respect to w and l with
respect to b
right and the short answer there is
chain rule
right and if you are if you are
familiar with multi-variable calculus if
you are already experts at taking
um applying the chain rule in a
multivariate setting
the rest of the lecture is probably
boring for you because all what we are
going to do
is apply chain rule of calculus
multivariable calculus
to calculate these gradients right and
that is pretty much all what back
propagation is
so back propagation is a fancy name
but the reason it's call back
propagation
is mathematically it is just the chain
rule
right but the way we go about
calculating the gradients
is we start from the end and work our
way backwards so algorithmically
right we we follow a particular sequence
of steps
which makes it appear that the gradients
are being calculated in a backward
fashion
right but mathematically it is just the
chain rule
right there's a difference between um a
mathematical answer and an algorithmic
answer right for the same mathematical
answer they can be multiple algorithmic
answers we saw that with kernels as well
right for the same for the same inner
product we could either
calculate the explicit feature
representation and take the inner
the dot product between them or we can
directly calculate
the kernel function right they're
they're mathematically equivalent but
algorithmically different
similarly the back propagation
mathematically is just
the chain rule right but algorithmically
we calculate it in a way such that it is
memory efficient and we reuse a lot of
the computation
while when uh when when
we reuse a lot of the intermediate
computations when calculating right so
that's that's back propagation
ah and let's let's see how we go about
doing it
any question so far
before we we go into back propagation
there was a question asked earlier right
why
why can we not what would happen um or
rather the question was
wouldn't all the neurons in say the
first layer
learn the same thing right why why
aren't we just learning multiple copies
of the same logistic regression
and the answer there is if we perform an
initialization
where the entire network is initialized
to zeros all the weights and biases are
initialized to zeros
then that's exactly what will happen if
we start with the zero initialization
what we will observe is all the neurons
in every layer
are learning the same thing so we will
just end up having multiple copies
of the same neuron within a given layer
and in order to
avoid that problem we perform
what is called as a random
initialization which means we are going
to
initialize all the weights and and
biases in the network
in a random way by by calling a random
number generator
and and initializing them and this is
a necessary step which is um
also called symmetry breaking because
the network
is is is symmetric within a layer right
and in order to break that symmetry we
initialize them at a different run
at different random initializations and
because of that random initialization
they will end up learning different
functions
so each logistic regression will end up
learning within a layer is going to end
up learning different
weights and biases just because we have
star
we have started from a random
initialization in case of
logistic regression no matter where we
initialize from we always reach the same
answer
but over here in logistic regression we
always use the same answer because the
problem was convex
but once we are in a neural network
setting we lose convexity
this
this giant composition of functions in
general will not become
convex which means depending on
the initialization we are going to reach
a different solution
right and which is why random
initialization is is
is very necessary and the way we go
about
initializing is so um
w l
so in in
in logistic regression or in general in
our learning algorithms the way we
set about doing it is
initialize
w's and b's and then for
you know call it i in one through
sometime or rather t in some time step
you know
theta equals theta
minus alpha times something right in
order to do the initialization step
which in logistic regression and linear
models we would just initialize them to
zero
in that in in place of zero
initialization we will instead
do an initialization like this so w l
initialize it with a random number
generator gaussian random number
generator of
mean 0 and
square root of 2 over
n l plus
l minus 1 or this is one choice
or we could also do w of l
is uniform
minus 0.12 plus
0.1 there are many different
initialization schemes
so this is just you know random uniform
initialization
and and this is commonly done
this has a particular name it's called
um
year initialization
and this is another choice of
initialization and
what you will observe is the choice of
initialization is also a hyper parameter
when you are learning to fit your model
next question
so the superscript identifies what layer
each thing belongs to
so the question is you know is this
shared by every neuron in the layer
so the dimension of b1 is the number of
neurons
in that layer and each element of this
vector
corresponds to one neuron
right so this question
yeah so this over here is the number of
neurons in the health layer and the
number of neurons in the l minus one
layer
yeah we can we can uh discuss the the uh
reason for that uh probably if you
remind me again we will
uh uh we can discuss the reason for that
yes question
but what do you just get the same answer
like multiple copies
irrespective of what you choose because
it's just like if you see the second
layer and the first layer first layer
also means the input
and second layer of the nodes in the
container so it isn't
the suppose say the first node is w x
plus b
and the second one is
so the the question is um
is is won't all the nodes be the same
the
the the answer is no because w
is a matrix and
each row of the w matrix is associated
with each neuron
right and if w is initialized randomly
then each row
of w is going to be you know a different
different vector
right so
yeah so over here you know um
i should probably put this as w i j
right so each element of your w matrix
initialize it by performing a random
sample from
this question
yes when we are updating we need to
update so
you we can also see this as
you know w i j of l layer
equals w i j of l
minus alpha times partial
of the loss with respect to
w i j and this and this are equivalent
now this just vectorized notation
right so the training algorithm you know
first we initialize
w and b with some kind of initialization
and for each for each
iteration we have a nested loop
for l in
one two l
l equals
alpha times partial of
loss with respect to partial
similarly
right so this is going to be our our
high level algorithm first initialize
all the w's and b with some kind of a
chosen random initialization
right initialize the full network and
then for
each iteration we're going to
per we're going to take some examples
maybe one examples or maybe uh you know
a few examples and we're going to
calculate the gradient of the loss with
respect to the weights
and biases of each layer and perform a
gradient update
of each of the weights and bias
parameter
yes question
so what do you mean by weight one and
weight two do you mean the
weight by weight one do you mean the
first layer or the first iteration
so we'll see what the relation between
the weights are now
next so
now what i'm going to draw is you can
call it a computation graph
this this will allow us to understand
how all the different terms are
dependent on the loss right so
first i am going to have i will call
this
a 0 right and this is basically just
x and to this a 0
we are going to use
matrix w 1
and a bias
b one right
and here you know we have some
outcomes
z 1 and the computation that happens
here
so basically each um square or a
rectangle
is some vector right and
the clouds are basically computations
right so some some operation happening
here
and here the operation is z z
equals w a
plus b right
and now this goes
into a cloud of operation and comes out
as a one
and here the operation is a equals g of
z
right and similarly next
we have
w two
b two
some operation for which these go in as
inputs
and outcomes
z two z two and again
something else
this will call it ah a two
and again this is just g right and here
it is
z equals w a plus b
and let's just draw one more
right over here let's say we have
w 3
b 3
again z equals w
a plus b and we get
z3
another g
so ah for the sake of simplicity we will
assume that the final layer has just one
row
because we want a scalar
and b three will also be just a scalar
and z three is also a scalar
and we get a three
right and a three is also equal to
y hat right
and just going to continue it here
and we have y hat
and y
so one arrow comes into this cloud this
y comes in here and out comes our
loss right and the loss is also
a scalar
right we start with the input vector
right this the dimension of this is the
dimension of our data
right and the dimension of z
was a hyper parameter that we chose
right
and and the dimension of z the dimension
of a and
the dimension of b is equal to the
number of layers in the first
layer the number of neurons in the first
layer right
and the way we compute z is w
a plus b where the w's and b's are
coming here
um and so on we we we nest this by
you know we are adding depth and finally
we have a loss
right and what we want to do is take the
partial derivative
or the gradient of l with respect to
each w and take the partial derivative
of
l with respect to each base
right and then perform gradient update
this question
yeah so the question is what if y hat
was a vector
right um y hat would would uh um
in general y hat could be anything as
long as your loss is a scalar
right eventually we want the loss to be
a scalar
yeah so the question is could we not uh
append
uh um yeah so uh you know
have another have another uh one
extend the a vector by one and extend
another row
for uh w yeah you could you could do
that um in
um you you you could do that but uh in
practice w's and b's are kept
separate and there's a good reason for
that um
we saw the reason in svms if you
remember
that we were only penalizing the norm of
w
and not penalizing b and there's going
to be a similar reason why
where we we are going to perform
something called
regularization that's going to come in
the future only on w's and not on v so
it's for notation it's it's in this case
it's good to keep the b's and w's
separate
yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah if you
you you could do that i mean there is
mathematically they are the same
right uh you if you think of uh
if you at every layer if you extend
a uh
if you extend a by adding a one
then you can get rid of b sure you can
do that ah
but in practice you know ah it's it's
exactly the same but in practice
you know nobody does that anyways so now
the question is
how are we going to compute each of
these partial derivatives
of the final loss which is a scalar
right this is a scalar with respect to
this matrix this bias and you know
and so on and and that's where chain
rule comes to help
and that's what back propagation is all
about
okay so i am going to switch to that
board
so first we are going to make a few
observations
so for this example we are assuming
binary classification that is y's are
in zeros and ones and
y's are zeros and ones
but in general your y's could be
anything and your loss function could be
something here we're just assuming the
logistic class
right so first we will observe that
so we will work it out for w2
um and even in the notes we have done it
for w2 but the steps are exactly the
same for w1 w3 and b1 b3 right once once
you know how to do it for one you can
just apply
the same recipe for all of them so
partial of loss with respect to partial
w two
is equal to if you remember from our
matrix calculus review
is going to be partial of l
loss with respect to partial w
2 1 1
[Music]
partial
version w
two in this case uh in in in the notes
we
uh the second node has
three so w so
this had three but but in general you
know it's just uh
depending on the dimensions of w you
know you have
in this case it's just 1 3 and
right so this is a matrix and you take
the partial of this loss with respect to
every single element and arrange it as a
matrix
so this is it you know this is just the
definition of
a gradient of a scalar loss with respect
to
a matrix this question
w2 so second layer should we
start
so first let's work out the math and
then we look at the algorithm of how we
go about doing it so this is just math
you know what's what's the gradient of
of um yeah this is for the middle layer
this is the middle layer right and now
make a few more observations
right
so the partial of l
with respect to z 3
so what is z here z 3 is
so the partial of l with respect to
z 3 is
is equal to partial of
z 3 times
minus y log
y hat minus
1 minus y log
1 minus y hat right and this
works out to be
so i'm going to skip a few steps here
it's basically the same kind of
calculation you did with logistic
regression
and here this is minus y log
y hat is basically sigmoid
of z 3
minus 1 minus y
log 1 minus sigmoid
of z
three right and
you can do the steps this basically the
same kind of steps we did
for homework one question one part a
when you're when you're showing
um the positive definiteness of
the hessian of logistic regression you
would have calculated you know basically
the same steps and this simplifies to
a3 minus y so the partial
of l with respect to z 3 is equal to a 3
minus y
and now
we are now going to calculate the
partial
of each of these we are going to pick
one ijth element and see what
it turns out to be so partial of
l with respect to partial of
w i j of the second layer
is equal to
partial of l with respect to
partial of a 3
times partial of
a three with respect to partial of
w
to ij
right this is a chain rule any questions
with this
all good and then this we're going to
further break it down
times
partial love
any question from here to here again
just the chain rule
and so on and now we observe that
this um did i miss something z
[Music]
it oh so um
okay so one more step so partial of
l with respect to partial of a 3
times partial of
a 3 respect to partial of
z3 times
partial of
a
a3 to z3 and z3 to a2
portion of v3 respect to partial of
a2
names partial off
c2 times partial of
v2 times partial of z
let's see w
w two i j
right so basically apply the same thing
and
we get this this long expression right
and how did we reach this expression
to reach this expression
what we basically did is
you know applying the chain rule right
so
d z so d a two by d
z two is a jacobian because it's a
vector valued function
by a vector valued function right
so this is going to be so here we are
going to get
ah let me use the red to
denote the gradients so the partial
of l with respect to y hat
right over here so anywhere where
there's a computation
we get a gradient or a jacobian so
l with respect to y hat is going to be a
scalar
so i'm just going to denote it by a dot
there is another computation here output
to input and this is going to be
a scalar because the scalar it's a
scalar the the
derivative is going to be a scalar
from scalar to vector
so the derivative of a scalar valued
output times a vector valued input is
going to be a
a gradient of vector so i am going to
write it as
a vector right and the derivative of
vector
valued output by a vector valued input
is going to be a
a jacobian matrix so we are going to
have a
matrix here similarly
vector valued output to vector valued
input is going to be a
jacobian
right now the
the the ah the way we go about
doing this the common pattern that you
observe is that
you if the deeper your network is you're
going to have this alternating sequence
of z's and a's and z's and a's and z's
and a's
right and from every a to every z and
from every z
to every a you're going to have keep
getting jacobians
right and whenever there is a g
the jacobian because this is element
wise operation the jacobian is going to
be a diagonal matrix
right and over here also ah
this is going to be a diagonal matrix
whenever the non linearity comes into
picture
because it is an element wise operation
and whenever we
from z to a because z is w times
a you will observe that the jacobian
from z to a will always be
z will always be just w
yes question the weights are all
independent of each other
but in order to calculate the chain rule
what we do is we break them down into
local derivatives
yeah the the uh well what do you mean by
independent
matrix
so here the it is it is diagonal only
for the non-linearity because that's
just acting
element wise there is no interaction
between
you know the other terms you are just
performing an element wise
operation so this is going to be a
diagonal matrix
right and from z to a it is always going
to be the corresponding weight matrix
and from a to z it is always going to be
a diagonal matrix
right and no matter how deep you go you
are just going to keep getting this
diagonal matrix corresponding weight
matrix diagonal matrix corresponding
weight matrix
and so on right and now when we want to
calculate
the gradient of and the gradients that
we want to
update are for values over here
right these are the ones we want to
these are the
the parameters that we want to update
right so we want to calculate
the the the gradient of
the final loss with respect to this blue
dot
final loss with respect to this blue dot
and so on and construct our
update matrix right
because this matrix we saw is
you know each of this corresponds to a
blue dot
right so we want to calculate the
gradient of the final loss with respect
to each blue dot and
construct the corresponding update
matrix
and in order to calculate the final loss
with respect to the blue dot
we just apply the chain rule and the
chain rule says
back to the chain rule
the chain rule says each of these
are going to be this is going to be
so z to a is always going to be the
matrix w
of 3 a to z
is going to be a diagonal matrix
of g prime
and
this thing over here is what we
calculated already that is a3 minus y
right so we are going to get a3 minus y
times w3
times diagonal of g prime of z2
times this one now how do we handle this
so
once we bootstrap this no matter how
deep our network is
we're just going to keep adding on you
know the w matrix itself
and the diagonal of g prime the next w
matrix the next diagonal of g prime next
w matrix next diagonal of g
prime and that's going to be a recurring
pattern
and we just need to figure out the
starting end which we which is common
for all
which is just you know the a3 minus y
and
all the way at the beginning and for all
the way at the beginning
we are trying to calculate the gradient
of a vector times a scalar
right so this is a vector
and this is a scalar z z 2 is a vector w
i j
is a scalar right so in in our picture
now we are trying to calculate the
gradient of
the z vector
with respect to the scalar
and this is again pretty straight
forward
right and this turns out to be
so if if we are doing it for our w i j
this will just be a
matrix with zeros everywhere
except a
j of one in the
ith position right
and the reason is again pretty pretty
simple because z
is just w uh uh w a
plus b so the
the derivative with respect to w so
w i j can only influence the
ith element of z
w i j cannot so if if w i j
uh is is say from from the second row
so all these parameters of w can only
influence
the second uh second element of z
so the derivative of this vector with
respect to this is going to have zeros
everywhere else
and the influence of ijth element
on the ith element is just a j
so this is going to be just a j
in the ith position
any questions on this right
and and and so if if we kind of do a
dimensional
check this is 1 cross 1
w three is in this case
uh um in in the in the uh example in the
nodes it's one cross two
and this diagonal is going to be two
cross two with with only diagonal
entries
and this is going to be 2 cross 1
in that example there is
there is only that there is only 2 so
the other one will be 0 and a j will be
intelligent and now we can combine all
of these into
into single entry so this is basically a
minus y the scalar
times w 3
and when you multiply
a diagonal matrix with another matrix
you get a matrix
which is the same as performing element
wise multiplication
right when you multiply by diagonal
matrix
with a vector it's essentially the same
as performing element wise
multiplication
and this whole thing
is now a 1 by 2
times
aj which is two by one
this is the ith position right
and further
ah this can be further simplified as
a 3 minus y
times w 3 element wise
g prime of z
3 right and because it this is
0s in everywhere except the ith position
this vector we only need
the ith index times
a
j one
and this is for i j th element
so partial l with respect to w
i j is the i-th element of this vector
times
j-th element of this vector which means
partial l with respect to partial
w the full matrix is just the outer
product between these two vectors
right so that is a three minus y
w 3 g
prime z
3 so this is the vector from which we
took the i
element instead for the full matrix it's
going to be this vector outer product
with
aj 1 transpose
this question
it's a j 1 because we are calculating
with respect to w
2 and for w 2
sorry i should have kept the picture
here for w 2
a 1 is the thing it gets multiplied by
so what what what you see here is there
is um
a fair amount of notation but the main
idea to
to take away from this is the loss
is the final loss is always a scalar and
we want to take the
derivatives with respect to elements of
a given matrix
right and for that we
use the chain rule to
to start taking the gradient all the way
from
the final loss to the layer below
before to the layer before to the layer
before to the layer before
and each of those gives you a jacobian
and those jacobians have a repetitive
pattern
the very first time it is something
different
you know a3 minus y and this comes from
logistic regression
and then onwards all the jacobians
you're going to have this daisy chain of
jacobians
and they are very easy to compute
they're going to be the corresponding
weight matrix
or a diagonal of the derivative of the
activation function right
and you're going to have a daisy chain
of this of these jacobians
depending on how deep your network is
right and the dimensions are always
going to be such that
the output of this layer is going to be
the
input of this layer and the output of
this is going to be the input of this
and
you know they will always match in
dimensions
so we're going to start with a one by
one and going to end up with a one
and all the intermediate intermediate
dimensions where they
where the meat will always match and
once you
once you multiply this whole thing
you're going to end up with a scalar a
one by one
one by one solution and that's going to
be
the value you're going to fill in here
and then you repeat that when you repeat
that you see that
that one by one entry was basically the
product of the ith
element of one vector times the jth
element of another vector which means
the full matrix is just the outer
product between those two vectors
next question
yeah this should be you're right so this
should be 2. thank you
yeah it's a 2 2 over here i made it the
3 over there
right so that's basically that's
basically the applying the chain rule to
get the
the partial derivatives and basically
back prop is now
now this what what we see you know this
daisy
chain structure if we want to compute
the partial with respect to w1 now right
it's basically you're going to add
two more links into this daisy chain
okay into this daisy chain of jacobians
you're going to have two more jacobians
and the final
and and this is going to be specific to
the previous layer right
and basically backdrop tells you that if
we start computing
the the derivatives with respect to
matrix all the way from the end
then we can reuse the terms
we we don't have to recompute the the
the product of this which is going to be
a vector
for the next for the previous layer
we're just going to
have another w matrix and a diagonal
matrix
and the the corresponding a matrix
a a vector for the previous layer so we
can reuse all this computation when we
are calculating the
derivatives for the previous layer and
that's that's basically back propagation
it suggests you that you should
start working backwards so that you can
reuse computation
right any question yes question
yeah so so here we are you know uh
in this daisy chain you observe that we
are moving from vector to vector to
vector
right so the local derivative will be a
jacobian
with respect to vector exactly all right
so then we'll break